herzlich willkommen zu best of
heute-show unsere lieblings reportagen
ich habe mir viel arbeit gemacht
zusammen mit meinem guten kollegen lutz
van der horst
wir machen mediathek und youtube nicht
tik tok ein hochkant ja gott sei dank
wir haben uns den ganzen sommer frei
genommen um aus allen reportagen unsere
absoluten lieblingsstück herauszusuchen
es war hammer viel arbeit aber hey wir
haben es gerne gemacht ja und weil ich
genau wusste dass lutz nur videos von
sich heraus sucht menschen reporter in
solchen kategorien denke ich gar nicht
ich sehe nur witzigkeit und wenn er
jetzt zufällig immer nur sachen von mir
dabei sind naja und deswegen habe ich
nur videos von mir ausgesucht
du musst dich nicht entschuldigen das
fernsehen das ist ein häufig springer
ich weiß
und deswegen habe ich der regie auch 100
euro gegeben damit wir mit meiner
reportage anfangen ich sage ja immer
nutzt wenn du die rolling stones bis
dann ist völlig okay wenn es sie die
vorgruppe macht auf der ein sehr vorfilm
quasi man muss sagen der film hat
historische bedeutung denn das war mein
erstes mal im bundestag und macht ja
nichts raus das erste mal wird
eigentlich immer sterne und ich finde
man spürt total diese frische diese
jugend die ich diesem wert von gewissen
kollegen ja schon ziemlich herr
abgewirtschafteten formats wieder ein
gehauchter oma du bist so ein dreck
viele männer wenig frauen ziemlich voll
klingt nach disco ist aber der neue
bundestag
ich habe mir den ersten schultag der
abgeordneten mal an
er ist mir glaube ich ein größeres
parlament als indien
das ist schwierig und ich glaube dass
ich glück und yahoo
vielen dank na wie geht's dir was ich
noch habe ich wurde dass nico meckel
oder wie immer wäre es nicht sinnvoller
male obergrenze für abgeordnete zu
machen als für flüchtlinge von mir auf
200.000 die zeit wenn sie noch so geil
oder der neue bundestag ist ja der
männlichste bundestag seit langem
würden sie sich für die frauenquote
umoperieren lassen um operieren müsste
ich mich nicht lassen weil in unserer
fraktion die haben ja 40 prozent fahren
das ist ja eher die hfg und die cdu und
die csu darüber problem auch eine
einzelne op würde ja die gesamtquote
verbessern karl lauterbach glaube ich
also braucht das nicht also ich
denke beide geschlechter habt weil sie
hinzu wir haben nicht mal frauen
meistens intelligenter sind als männer
gegenseitig in die fdp ja das habe ich
zu viel an zdf-reihe sich als
intelligenter sind als männer
ja das ist richtig es nicht an da ich
mir jetzt auch der intendant versteht
die andere frau heute schon gedacht von
der frau bot er ihr nur vorwärts zu
gehen ist ja quasi erster schultag die
abgeordneten kommen ins haus
ja das ist meine schultüte ja schon
gepackt oder sind das schon afd kisten
die hier ihr zeugte von mottenkiste
aber sie haben ja gesagt jetzt wird
ausgemistet aufgeräumt könnte man nicht
mit der afg anfangen nein überhaupt
nicht
wollen wir mit den altparteien aufräumen
und deren politik
sie müssen sich jetzt wieder stellen ach
so ich dachte werden irgendwas
inhaltliches noch zu sagen
was ich ja kurios fand ist dass die afg
die ersten waren die irgendwie
angemeldet haben dass ihnen die räume zu
klein sind finde ich ziemlich bonzen
partei mäßig also als ich hier
eingezogen bin 2009 waren wir drei
monate mit vier leuten in so einem raum
das war auch stressig wären sie denn
bereit theoretisch ihr büro mit einem
mal auf dem board und zu teilen wenn es
sich vermeiden lässt würde ich es gerne
vermeiden
aber wenn sie alexander gauland zum
beispiel aufnehmen würden hätte das
ganze auch noch so einen pflegerischen
aspekt ja weiß ich nicht wann sie stehen
sonst sonst muss ich sie jagen
wie war der erste schultag war
sicherlich ein bisschen auch mit
neugierde gesetzt aber letztlich war es
auch ein spannender tag und ich glaube
dass es gelingen wird dass wir ganz
schnell integrierter teil dieses
parlaments
also hier im deutschen bundestag sind
sie jetzt für integration aber wenn vom
flüchtlinge wert nicht so oder so ist
jetzt ein weites feld
ich weiß auch nicht wie man also die
integration in die politik betrieb ist
und zusammen dass auch einfacher und
schöner als flüchtlinge zu integrieren
oder miene
also ich glaube wir sollten das auch die
geschäftsgrundlage verständigen wie wir
miteinander okay wenn sie mit mir
politisch streiten wollen dann lassen
sie die zahlen okay eine frage noch nie
ich wollte ja abschiede minister werden
tatsächlich jens das ministerium arbeit
gibt ja die migrations ministerium dann
werde ich ein bisschen relegation die
negation ministerium und dann wird
abgeschrieben und haken sie eigentlich
wirklich das klingt prima zion kriegen
sie einen orgasmus
das haben jetzt sie gesagt aber schon
der staat ist vorüber die abgeordneten
mussten direkt zwei stunden nachsitzen
da gab es lange gesichter sie sind jetzt
froh dass sie nach hause dürfen ans
buffet mal sehen was mutti gekocht hat
also nachdem ich den beitrag gesehen
habe muss ich doch noch mal sagen du
bist echt besser geworden danke echt
prima wenn du da jetzt dran bleibst und
fleißig an der arbeit ist verwirrend
du meinst dann kann ich auch mal im
fernsehgarten den hofnarren geben
du bist nur neidisch weil die wichtig
nicht zu unserem tupper partys einladen
sicher hat thailand nach dem beitrag
eigentlich jemals wieder mit ihr geredet
nein aber frage ihn doch mal woran es
liegt ich glaube er ist kernzielgruppe
im fernsehgarten meister fabian diese
schärfe die jetzt hier reinkommt das
muss doch nicht sein oder
ich mein es ist sommer es ist internet
wir haben die besten reportagen von mir
und von dir ist auch ein bisschen was
dabei ja komm du hast ja recht ich meine
das nächste video da geht es echt um
alles es geht um visionen eine bessere
welt gerechtigkeit zukunft und deshalb
kann ich bis heute nicht verstehen warum
sie da dich hin geschickt haben
[Applaus]
sozialismus das bedeutet ja im prinzip
die die viel haben sollen den die
weniger haben etwas abgeben
jetzt haben sie sehr viele süßigkeiten
hier muss man sagen da dürfen sie gerne
was nehmen denn ich gebe gerne wasser
danke gott dass er uns geschenkt mein
team und ich wir wollen frau aus essen
gehen könnte ich vielleicht 20 von
meinen euros haben 20 von ihren euros an
unserer nutzer alles und sozialisten ja
aber wir sind immer noch in einer
gesellschaft in der der einzelne eine
bestimmte leistung erbringen muss zehn
euro 10 euro das betrifft das gleiche
ist es das prinzip also ich würde mich
mal ne wurst ausgeben 'jetzt oder das
wenn sie in meine botschaft wenn sie in
not jahren würde ich um einen mikrofon
geben sie den bus zdf in not ist lachen
muss man jetzt auch nicht drüber
[Applaus]
[Musik]
worüber haben sie sich jetzt genau an
meinem gesicht kann auch noch näher
kommen noch ein dann kann ich mir noch
eine cola holen euro ja danke genossen
das ist soziales am gleichen morgen das
stimmt tatsächlich jetzt gehen sie mir
ihr handy nein das kann ich meinte ich
bin ja ein ding gab ja dann sind andy
brown ale handy auch das gibt es doch
nicht weshalb wir handy
[Musik]
frau wagenknecht stichwort kapitalismus
jetzt mal ernsthaft freuen sie sich
nicht ein bisschen über den ganzen
schlamassel
naja freuen kann man sich darüber nun
nicht gerade aber es zeigt natürlich
dass vieles was linke vorhergesagt haben
eben leider auch wirklich so ist und sie
hatten zum ersten mal recht kann man
sagen ja recht zu haben ich wünsche mir
vor allem dass unsere konzepte umgesetzt
werden was bei den linken die großen
schwachstellen neben lötzsch und ernst
also ein
neben lösung er hat das weiß ich
natürlich zurück wenn man den gedanken
jetzt konsequent weiterdenkt das im
staate allen alles gehört laufe ich ja
jetzt im prinzip in ihrer unterwäsche
rum ist das okay für sie natürlich nicht
unser konzept sondern wir wollen
wirtschafts eigentum vergesellschaften
und sie müssen sich keine sorgen um ihre
unterwäsche machen
sie wollen im prinzip
öffentlich-rechtliche banken da muss ich
ihnen als zdf mitarbeiter sagen
öffentlich-rechtlich das hat noch nie
funktioniert
das ist erstaunlich dass hier als pdf
reader weiter das sagen ich muss ich
muss ihnen sagen in der krise haben sich
gerade sparkassen bewährt das weiß jeder
zu hören hier dazu höre ich hoffe dass
sie es nicht wechseln halten jetzt und
deshalb
wahnsinn zwei kaffee eine wurst einen
batzen süßigkeiten ein handy und 3 euro
schade dass nicht jeden tag
linken-parteitag mehr denn dann würde
ich ganz bestimmt nicht mehr für dich
arbeiten welche das war übrigens das
erste mal dass ich mit oskar lafontaine
geredet habe und er dachte tatsächlich
sei ein seriöser reporter vom
kinderfernsehen nein vielleicht aber das
lag nur an dass ich die spongebob socken
an hatte und den spongebob rucksack und
die brotdose und egal aber das tolle ist
bei den linken da sind immer alle
supernett ja das ist es halt wenn man
nichts hat dann hat man auch keine angst
das einem irgendjemand irgendetwas
wegnimmt ja das wäre so schön wenn alle
alles gehören würde das wäre viel
weniger stress stimmt und du müsstest
einfach nur dein erster klasse upgrade
nach thailand mit allen zuschauern vom
fernsehgarten teilen chip können wir das
gerade rausschneiden dann werde ich doch
fdp
ok so dann kommen wir zur nächsten
lieblings reportage würde ich sagen und
die isv ich ich ich ich
mindestalter 18 jahre warum gilt das bei
der bundeswehr bisher nur für die
ausrüstung ist doch eine gute antwort ja
klar geht sie muss wieder anschaut klage
zu gute antwort ja bei der ausrüstung
ging es einfach daran dass wir die
bundeswehr über jahre kaputt gespart
haben deswegen ist die ausrüstung zu alt
und das junge leute mit 17 drei viertel
da jetzt anfangen ihren wehrdienst zu
leisten habe ich kein problem mit
ehrlich gesagt zu meiner zeit hat noch
eine wirklich gegeben also ich habe auch
mal eine 15 monate gemacht und
nachhinein
ich hab nicht darunter gelitten sieht es
ja auch an hus sind bei der csu also
schaden haben sie schon genommen
ich habe zivildienst geleistet und habe
dabei fotokopierer repariert haben sie
hängt gedient nein ich werde nicht
zurücktreten ich mit dem der nicht
gedient der weiß wovon er spricht ja
auch nicht gibt
der ist den grünen ich habe fotos
öffentlich rechtlicher rundfunk ist dann
mache ich mich als ja aber da kümmere
ich mich als zivi genug um die alten
leute gute kita ist jetzt mit angehört
aber das wäre auch das wäre auch so eine
option also wie die jungen wie jung
müssen soldaten sein und kann man dann
nebenbei vielleicht auch den mangel an
kitaplätzen lösen verbinden es werde
aber abstruse also gut dass sie keine
politische verantwortung haben sie
gedient
ein altes weiches sucht man jetzt ist
das vorstellen jetzt nach ich bin gut
für den volksglauben als wenn nichts
mehr reicht dann kommen frauen und 60
plus und dann leute vor allen dingen
großen passt auch wasser
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dass jugendliche bevor sie
entscheidungen treffen
das risiko wenig abwägen aber das ist ja
fürs militär optimal eigentlich oder
dass man sich fragt wo vorsicht abwägen
können sonst ja nachher nein ich will
gleich auch ein paar jugendliche
rekrutieren ich gehe in einem
jugendzentrum haben sie da vielleicht
ein paar psychotricks sicherlich sollten
sie nicht mit fakten und informationen
argumentieren was sinnvoller wäre es für
jugendliche adäquate anreizsysteme zu
schaffen
mega so habe ich mich mal zdf auch ein
köder dankeschön
hey bock auf krieg nein ok folgender dir
wenn ihr jetzt in 24 monats vertrag
abschließt kriegt ihr das neue iphone
dazu der empfang ist nicht immer gute
den krisengebieten aber besser als in
deutschland
ja ich brauche und ich mag samsung der
mann zu werden der ich nie war möchte
ich nicht wenn wir zurückkommen
aus dem krieg habt ihr krasse
geschichten zu erzählen also wenn er
zurückkommt muss man fairerweise sagen
also ja genau dieses wenn also ich
möchte erst wenn dann überhaupt
zurückkommen
außerdem gehe ich in den krieg um coole
geschichten zu erzählen
ihr habt freie auswahl totaler jungs
überschuss es gibt sonst noch mal
maschinenbaustudium mich auch soldaten
wir sind wir hin zu breit wie kann ich
dir den den bund irgendwie schmackhaft
machen habt ihr ein interesse an
autogramm von fabian köster der junge
lutz van dorst wer ist lutz wanderung
[Applaus]
und jetzt kommen wir auch schon zum
großen finale
ich wollte doch headliner sagen jetzt
hast du mir da auch das ist so unfair
und ich ich ich ich ich ich okay
andererseits wenn du auf ein konzert
geben
dann hast du deine vorbild dann noch nur
vorband und bei sehr großen künstlern
kommt dann der mct der oberknaller und
dann später auf dem weg zur u bahn
dann steht ja noch mal so ein dünner typ
der die besten hits vom welt da noch mal
in kleiner nach spielt ja und das bis
jetzt du weißt du so viel liebe und gute
stimmung die wir hier entgegen schwappt
das erinnert mich ein bisschen an das
thema unserer top lieblings reportage
das große finale aus baden württemberg
von der korona demo das ist ein super
lustige reporter
du weißt aber schon dass sie nicht von
dir ist was viele nicht wissen der welt
und ich wir haben dich quasi nach meinem
antlitz erschaffen also insofern kommt
das jetzt echt eine rote linie kollege
das geht nicht
nicht mama mit kruste place und spätzle
mit soß mir ist aufgefallen dass sehr
viele schreiben hier sind exakt da
beginnt revolution im schwabenland ende
täglich deine
keine chance wird sehr peinlich für sie
frau merkels wird sehr peinlich und für
dich auch wenn endlich deine spätzle ist
laut krone keine chance lassen sie mich
so zurückhaltend wie möglich fragen was
ist eigentlich das problem der schwaben
aber haben jetzt zum einen ein
kritisches milieus wir haben ein relativ
starkes ätherisches milieu auch hier im
südwesten dass auch corinna
verschwörungstheorien glaubt und es gibt
glaube ich so eine gewisse protestkultur
gerade hier in baden württemberg dass
man vielleicht auch nicht so das hat was
man so libertäre positionen nennen
könnte wo man sich vom staat möglichst
wenig reinreden lassen möchte bühne
unterwegs und streite für
die rückgabe meine grundrechte ich bin
bewegt weil ich sehe dass das dicke
verdreht werden wissenschaftlich aus
meiner zunft sogar was ist die zunft
medizin
ich bin arzt was für eine art guter
hoffe ich und reicht es wenn man einen
mindestabstand zur wissenschaft ein
ich meine dass man dann gesichert ist
welche wissen schon was meinen sie du
machst verstehe ihre frage nicht also
wenn sie mich nur provozieren wollen
dann sie haben sie den falschen
gesprächspartner
sie sind auch nicht vom zdf sb haben sie
nur sie sehen von der linken warum haben
viele dieser verschwörungstheoretiker so
ein wahnsinniges mitteilungsbedürfnis
verschwörungstheoretiker die man so
trifft auf diesen demonstrationen dieses
kino ihn überzeugt davon dass sie
erkannt haben was wirklich vor sich geht
das tut mir sehr leid dass du getötet
wurdest weil dann kommt sie jetzt in die
hölle neues weise fragen wo kommen sie
hin
ich komme in den himmel und was ist im
himmel so nah himmel ist spaß friede
freude eierkuchen und bei dir ist halt
arsch lecken und wollen das natürlich
verbreiten wollen andere leute auch
überzeugen davon die welt so zu sehen
wie sie sie sehen und deshalb ist es so
dass man entweder gar nicht mit denen
ins gespräch kommt die frage warum
oder wenn es funktioniert wird man sie
nie mehr wieder los ich schieße wie baue
ich eine richtig gute
verschwörungstheorie eine richtig gute
verschwörungstheorie da brauchen sie
erst mal eine dunkle gruppe der sie das
alles in die schuhe schieben dürfen zdf
zdf zum beispiel aber das reicht da
nicht das zdf muss mit irgendwem anderes
gemeinsame sache machen sagen wir mit
den illuminaten und mit schalke 04
ja also eine perfekte
verschwörungstheorie wäre das zdf will
mit hilfe der illuminaten schalke 04 zum
deutschen meister machen
das halte ich für fast so abstrus 114
deutschen meister zu machen dass das
nicht mehr die verschwörungstheorien
glauben aber wir wissen aus erfahrung
die abstruse desto mehr wird das
geklappt wer steckt hinter dem betrug
das sind die so genannten 400 familien
das sind die menschen denen die
internationalen konzerne gehören die
gerade praktisch am end im endzustand
des monopolist muss angelangt sind und
uns in ein neues mittelalter befördern
wollen die uns weltweit entrechten und
verelenden wollen die stecken dahinter
also ist abstand halten und maske tragen
quatsch ist absoluter quatsch
warum halten sie dann soviel abstand zum
gesunden menschenverstand frechheit eine
frechheit ich wurde auch nichts machen
ich bin hier informiert warum zwiebeln
und ich wehre mich dagegen was hier
gesagt wurde gilt nicht für alle
schreiben dieses ich habe mal einen
x-beliebigen schwaben auf der straße
angesprochen vielleicht stellen sie sich
erst mal vor einer bestünde oettinger
querdenker sollten auch argumente prüfen
erklärt denken ist eine verpflichtung
dass man die besseren argumente sucht
und nicht schwachsinn wirtschaft in
jeder pflanze in jedem tier in jeder
begegnung in jeder zwischenmenschlichen
begegnung ist die liebe zu denen auch
zwischen uns exakt genau und ob die das
zulässt oder nicht das liegt an dir und
hast du was zugelassen
ja ich war ganz kurz davor aber dann ist
mir eingefallen das bisschen liebe dass
ich nach zehn jahren arbeit mit tieren
auch in mir trage das spare ich mir auf
um später noch all unsere videos auf
youtube zu leiden ja und das könnt ihr
jetzt auch machen also ist natürlich
komplett freiwillig aber wenn euch das
jetzt nicht gefallen hat profil wir uns
hier den arsch auf reisen wofür wir
alles geben dann hab dann wäre das
wirklich sein
wann darf man darf den therapeuten ich
aus der quarantäne so freunde und jetzt
nochmal ordentlich stimmung machen hier
im kanal von bisher sicher dass ich hier
richtig stehe ja ich habe das exakt
ausgemessen wobei du kannst du dich noch
ein zwei schritte nach vorne gehen ja
und wenn ihr mehr comedy auf diesem
niveau haben wollt dann abonniert doch
einfach diesen kanal haut ein paar
daumen raus oder findet mehr zum lachen
auf comedy punkt zdf.de irgendwas fühlt
sich komisch an